what did galaxy's cloud formations your
nervous system mountain ranges and
coastlines all have in common they all
contain neverending patterns known as
fractals a classic example of a fractal
in nature is broccoli in that the whole
stalk is a similar version of one of its
branches so cut off one piece and you're
left with a smaller version of the
entire broccoli snowflakes are another
example it's often said that no two
snowflakes they're ever the same and
fractals offer a fascinating explanation
as to why nature works in this way my
nature continuously creates new
self-replicating yet unique structures
and how the smallest things in existent
and necessary components of the greater
whole the term fractal was coined by
Benoit Mandelbrot who was working at
computer giant IBM in 1980 Mandelbrot
had been fascinated by discoveries of
mathematicians from the early 19th
century who are attempting to define
their understanding for a curve it
experiments such as Georg Cantor's
discovery that a single line could be
divided forever and helga von Koch his
triangle a shape that has an infinite
perimeter but finite area resulted in
the term monsters Mandelbrot used the
modern computing powers developed by IBM
to run these monster equations millions
of times over this process led him to a
break for equation combining the
patterns found in previous monsters
resulting in his own set of numbers this
would become known as the Mandelbrot set
an infinite geometrical visualization of
a fractal one of the most amazing things
about the Mandelbrot set is that
theoretically if left by itself would
continue to create infinitely new
patterns from the original structure
proving that something could be
magnified forever fractal geometry is
currently applied in many fields for
example research into climate change and
the trajectory of dangerous meteorites
helping with cancer research by helping
to identify the growth of mutated cells
it's even believed by some that the
universe itself may be a fractal and as
you zoomed in discover it made up of
billions of galaxies
inside of those galaxies you would find
trillions of stars and billions of solar
systems and planets and on one of those
planets you would find her on earth you
would find continents cities and a human
and inside of that human you would find
a brain made of millions of cells in
which you would find trillions of
synapses firing away and inside of those
who would find DNA inside DNA you would
find atoms electrons protons neutrons
deeper still you'd find quartz neutrinos
and so on and then just maybe
continuously deeper into infinity some
believe that due to their highly complex
and mysterious nature the greatest use
of fractals is yet to be discovered
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon